So what is the power of procedural rigging?
Well, that comes from understanding
what procedural rigging is.
Now, the concept is to create a more efficient
and flexible rig that will speed up the rigging workflow
and have the ability to be shared
across multiple skeletal meshes within your project.
So it automates and accelerates the creation of controls
and other rig elements using the construction event,
which we'll look at in a bit more detail in a moment,
but this event is essentially the event that allows you
to create and position things
like your controls automatically.
And it simplifies the process of updating rigs
when a skeletal mesh changes.
So if you've made any updates to your skeletal mesh,
say your character now has an extra arm
and anything else that you've changed,
a procedural rig can automatically re-rig itself
as long as the bone names follow the same naming structure.
And it doesn't matter what that naming structure is,
that's something you can define,
but as long as you are consistent with it.
And it's a powerful template rig to use
with all of your skeletal meshes.
So you can build one rig and use that
with all of the characters in your project.
Again, this is heavily dependent
on your naming conventions,
so keeping them consistent will allow for this.
And it's ideal if you're needing to create hundreds
of controls for a character,
so a character that might have very complex rig,
many, maybe many facial controls
or many like small tweaking controls.
So procedural rigging will allow you
to automatically create those controls
as well as position them.
So it's eliminating a lot of that manual work.
But one thing to note is
that it's not like an easy rig button.
So you do need to be mindful about things
like your hierarchy and naming conventions
so that you're able to share this
across all of the skeletons in your project.